parents reach out to me and say hey mr
webb if our kids don't go back to school
i'm going to lose my job because i've
got to stay home with my child
this is a never-ending drumbeat with
really no end in sight
it's not the best it's not what we want
it to be but it's where we are
we're still arguing about mass and
science and safety
and whether or not that the virus is a
hoax as students across the country
prepare to return to school in the midst
of a pandemic the big questions on the
minds of parents students and teachers
or whether it will be safe to return to
the classroom in the fall of 2020
and if it is safe what will learning
look like
one state that is struggling to answer
those questions is illinois
in parts of the state where the
coronavirus cases and deaths are spiking
administrators are being cautious in
august the chicago public school system
announced that its entire first semester
would be remote
in other parts of illinois outside
chicago residents disagree with a
mandate from governor j.b
pritzker requiring masks in schools
since i've been
active here in the city of quincy this
has been the most divisive issue that
we've seen
in quincy we're very distrustful of
edicts coming down from chicago you'll
see signs here in quincy illinois that
says quincy is not chicago
and certainly our way of life is a lot
different
[Music]
hey nice to meet you i'm doug roy we
came up with
that we're going to do in person
instruction bring kids into the school
we're going to have a remote option if
parents don't feel right for any reason
they can choose to do that remote
learning plan
across the country schools are assessing
their own community's risk
and in many cases adopting their own
hybrid learning models
that include both remote and in-person
options
we're going to require masks we're going
to social distance as best we can
as you come into the schools you're
going to get your temperature taken
recently the mother of a quincy 4th
grader sued the city school district
over mask and temperature checked
requirements
that have been handed down by the
illinois state board of education
the mother claims that she and her child
would suffer irreparable injuries
and that the requirements infringed on
her child's right
to an in-person education within the
public school
there are parents that are encouraging
school boards in some areas of the state
to open without masks that is against
the rules in the state of illinois
the case is still ongoing the mother's
attorney said that she hasn't yet made
up her mind about whether her child will
go to school remotely or attend class
with a mask
the lawsuit that took place did it upset
the town
i think there's both sides of that
argument there are differing viewpoints
in town on on masks on
the covet 19 and all the information
coming out just like the rest of the
country
webb knows something about working in
challenging conditions the former
brigadier general with the u.s army
national guard in iowa
served tours in iraq and afghanistan
i've been in combat
and nothing compares to to what we've
done since march it's a it's difficult
it's stressful for my teachers for my
staff
and for our community in quincy that
division is on full display
on residents lawns but webb told me that
most of the tension in the town can be
found online
i'm on social media quite a bit it's
part of my job as superintendent so
i read the debates and i read what they
call you if you wear a mask i read what
they call you if you don't wear a mask
and
it's that's that's a bit discouraging
in july webb became so frustrated with
the division in town that he wrote a
post on facebook about the lawsuit
calling for unity within the community i
harbor no
animosity toward the mother i believe
she is trying to do what is best for her
child
all our parents in the blue devil family
are stressed tired and a little upset
they are just trying to do the best they
can
at the elementary school i talked to
principal chrissy cox to understand how
she is preparing her teachers
and i'm chrissy i'm doug nice to meet
you nice to meet you i'm going to show
you something that we've done with our
nursing offices
we've created a healthy office and then
we've also created a
sick office so if students are having
any
symptoms of kovid they would come to the
sick nursing station
you know if they just have need an ice
pack or a band-aid
they're gonna come to the healthy office
this is our inexpensive way of ensuring
that students can meet in small groups
so we're going to provide these for
classroom teachers
schools in quincy have received funds
through the cares act to supply students
and teachers with masks and sanitizer as
well as modify classrooms
but according to web those funds are
limited no longer do students sit
in desks and rows the classroom really
looks different
courtney erft is a fourth grade teacher
at denman physically my room is pretty
much how it's going to be
when the first day of school comes so
this year they're
facing the same direction and they're
separated
this way and this way as much as they
can be
to accommodate to physical distancing
last year
they were set up to be collaboratively
learning so they were put into groups
this year they're going to be more in
rows and separated
what do you what's the book the
quarantine books been for
so this year to keep kids safe with
checking out books in our library
we will have a band that they will put
the book in when they're done with it
so typically in the past when they're
done with the book they just put it back
in whatever bin they got it from
with the town divided principal cox
explained how she was handling the
disagreements on her own team
one of the things that is really
important to me
is relationship and ensuring
that we can maintain a positive
relationship even if we have
a disagreement on how things are going
to be
so quite honestly masks are a huge
you know this right like masks are a
huge
um topic of conversation and so
i've shared with my staff like we're
going to continue to follow
the guidelines and the guidelines are we
that we're wearing a mask to school it
is not our job to come to school
until uh and and tell people how we feel
about masks with whether we're pro mask
or anti-mass like that's not our job our
job is to is to wear a mask
but some residents are skeptical that a
return to in-person classes can be
successful
even if masks are required it's been
disappointing that our political
leadership hasn't taken more of a stance
of enforcing
simple measures to impor to help with
our safety
linda mccarty has been an educator in
the quincy area for 25 years
our daughter has chosen the online
academy
we um we looked at the science we looked
at the data
and made the decision that was best for
our family
we feel that it's too dangerous to send
her back into a large school setting
as of august 13th adams county which is
home to quincy
had 580 positive cases and seven deaths
so when you look at that data it appears
very safe but
just within the last three weeks our
numbers have spiked so we're starting to
see the trend that maybe the coastlines
or the largest
cities saw in the beginning schools
nationwide face uncertainty due to the
pandemic
and many have changed their plans
superintendent roy webb says there's a
50 50 chance whether quincy schools will
reopen
as of today students are set to be back
in the classroom on august 20th
[Music]
in combat you get a deployment you also
usually get an end date
when you're coming home we don't know
when our end date is